at any time when we had
security
i always got in more trouble because we
had security oh yeah like it would give
me this sense of confidence like when we
filmed uh jackass number two in new
orleans and uh
we um had like armed security with us
right and uh i was responsible for
for uh riling up some folks who ended up
like really badly assaulting jeff
tremaine right yeah you shoved him i
shoved him yeah he probably told that
story of the truth why would you have
security like what
he was post hurricane katrina new
orleans and like crime was just going
crazy and like everything was in pretty
uh
unstable shape i think they just made
like all productions have security and i
wasn't there when you initially pushed
the guy but yeah so you pushed these
guys came they were from
like a group of people in new orleans
that i think
with bam or something apparently with
cky apparently they've gotten into a
fight at like at the house of blues
during the cky show and so they heard
the jackass guys are in this hotel so
these guys like show up that would never
be in this lounge and they they go i
guess i wasn't the guy goes up to
knoxville he says hey why don't you buy
me a drink you're rich [ __ ] buy me a
drink and not so says i did i got you a
white russian but i might have [ __ ] in
it and then i go up and [ __ ] shove
the dude across the whole bar into the
arms of our security dude who drags him
out
and uh that that
kind of riled him up a little bit said
that'll do it
yeah later on some of the guys were at a
bar and i was with him and i went to go
get a sandwich and then shawna calls me
and was like jeff got a got a bike lock
like smashed over his head that wouldn't
happen if pontius was there
no
you know what i would have stopped it
from happening you know kept it cool you
would have disarmed him i would have
disarmed him you would have submitted
him
maybe a little late maybe maybe a little
late yeah after he tapped i'd let him
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and sky
jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]
bye